NAVNEET JONEJA: Hello
and welcome.
My name is Navneet Joneja I am
the lead product manager for
Compute Engine.
MARTIN GANNHOLM: And I am
Martin Gannholm, the
engineering manager for
Compute Engine.
NAVNEET JONEJA: Over the past
several months, Compute Engine
has evolved to become faster,
better, more cost effective
and easier to use.
And we're here to talk to you
about what that means for you
as a developer, and for the
applications you can
build in the Cloud.
Now a quick note about
level of depth.
This is a short session, so
the goal here is really to
make this a fire starter.
We're going to talk to you about
what Compute Engine is
about, talk to you about several
of the new features,
but not go into significant
amount of
technical depth on them.
We have additional deep dive
sessions about everything
we're talking about today, and
we'll give you pointers to the
sessions at the end
of our talk.
MARTIN GANNHOLM: And we also
have a Q&A at the end, so you
can ask us deeper technical
questions if you want then.
OK.
So let's start talking
about infrastructure.
So this is a picture of one
of our data centers.
And this is the infrastructure
that everything Google does as
a service runs on.
Now infrastructure includes
both the hardware and the
networks that we have, but it
also includes the software
infrastructures that we have
built, and Urs talked about
some of this earlier today.
This is the infrastructure that
powers our web search.
It allows us to crawl more
than 20 billion web pages
every single day.
It's the same infrastructure
that also serves up more than
four billion hours of
video every month.
It also is the same
infrastructure that powers
Compute Engine and the other
Cloud platform services.
And so you get to take advantage
of running on this
infrastructure that we've
developed over the last 14
plus years when you run
on Compute Engine.
So let me cover a few of
our core principles.
Being highly secure is one of
our fundamental principles,
and so that takes three forms.
One is encapsulation.
The primary form of
encapsulation is, of course,
your virtual machine.
We also encapsulate the network,
so all of your
Compute Engine instances are
connected to each other on a
private encapsulated network.
And they're connected regardless
of which zone or
which region across the globe
your instances are running in.
The second dimension
is access.
We restrict access to your
virtual machines by default.
And so the only port that is
open to communicate from the
outside world is through
the SSH.
Now, you can choose to open up
other ports in the firewall to
allow other traffic in.
You can also choose to remove
your public IP address from
the instance and thereby
cutting it
off from the internet.
And you can only reach it from
other virtual machines inside
of your cluster.
Third form of security that
we employ is encryption.
So all of the block device
storage that you use, whether
that is the scratch disk or
system disk storage, is
encrypted at rest, and is
encrypted as it leaves in the
virtual machine monitor and
before it hits the disk.
NAVNEET JONEJA: So at Google
we treat performance as a
first class feature.
It's not just another attribute
of a service.
And this goes back to our early
days when we designed
our consumer sites to be as fast
as possible, because we
believe that there's a strong
correlation between speed and
engagement.
And so it reflects itself in the
infrastructure we build.
Our physical machines are built
to be very fast and very
consistent, and it
reflects itself
every step of the stack.
So not only do you get to build
on great Infrastructure,
the software itself is
architected to be highly
consistent and highly
performant.
So how does that show up
in Compute Engine?
Well first it shows up in the
performance of the virtual
machines you can launch
in Compute Engine.
So you can launch a two core
virtual machine anywhere in
Compute Engine and get
the same performance.
So the consistency and the
performance are both
attributes built into the
architecture of Compute Engine.
It also is present in
our storage layer.
Now, in many cases, the
performance of the storage
layer is at least as important
as the performance of the
actual virtual machine.
And so we've built both our
scratch and our persistent
disk solutions, which are short
lived and sort of highly
available redundant reliable
storage solutions, to be very
fast and very consistently
performant.
And this has been demonstrated
by many benchmarks run by some
people in the audience
today even.
Another aspect of performance
for us is network performance.
Now network is really what
Google does, right?
It's fundamentally core
to all our businesses.
And so over the past 14 years,
we've done a lot of research
in the area of networking.
We've published several
papers.
This morning, if you were at
Urs' talk, he was talking
about how we run on
a software defined
network for all of Google.
And you'll find that that
research and that thinking
about network performance is
pervasive and is reflected in
Compute Engine.
Because when you spin up virtual
machines, you get
extremely high cross sectional
bandwidth between virtual
machines in Compute Engine.
And you also get great
performance to the broader
network as well.
Finally, we also believe
that scale and speed
of scaling is important.
Because, it turns out, that you
don't always get heads up
about a load that's
coming your way.
Right?
By the time you know you need to
scale, it's often too late.
And so when you need to scale,
you want to be able to spin up
virtual machines as quickly
as possible.
And so we focused on making that
spin up process quick and
painless so that you can scale
up quickly and effectively on
Compute Engine.
So how does that reflect
in the product
that you get to use?
Well, so a great example is our
partner MapR Technologies
who used our off-the-shelf
virtual machines to run the
benchmark called Minute
Sort Benchmark.
This benchmark measures
how much data you
can sort in a minute.
It's kind of the gold standard
for big data processing.
And MapR was able to sort one
and a half terabytes of data
in one minute on Compute Engine,
beating the previous
record that was set
on dedicated
tuned physical hardware.
So I hope that gives you a sense
of what you can do when
you have access to not just fast
virtual machines, but to
a fast network connecting
those virtual machines.
MARTIN GANNHOLM: All right.
Another core principle
is openness.
We start by providing an easy
to use API layer that we
expose to you, the developers.
That is also the same API layer
that we use as we build
higher level tools.
For example, command line tools
or the Cloud Console is
built accessing the exact same
APIs that you have access to.
Another form of openness is we
really want developers and
partners to be adding to the
ecosystem, building solutions
on top of Compute Engine and
the greater Cloud platform.
And so we've worked with the
community to provide both
CentOS and Debian images as
part of Compute Engine.
NAVNEET JONEJA: Now all that
doesn't really mean very much
unless it translates into
benefits that you can see and
that benefits you.
And we're very happy that our
customers and partners have
noted that our focus on
performance and security
address what they're hearing
from their customers as their
top concerns when they
move to the Cloud.
Here's a quote from Thorsten
von Eicken, the CTO of
RightScale, one of the
largest providers of
Cloud management software.
MARTIN GANNHOLM: So Compute
Engine is not an island.
I spoke earlier about
the Cloud platform.
So to build really sophisticated
services, you
often need to use multiple
different pieces in order to
build a complex application
solution.
And so we're really excited that
today we announced that
Cloud Datastore is basically
taking what has been the
world's largest hosted NoSQL
database, which is App Engines
Datastore, processing more than
four and a half trillion
operations per month, and making
that available through
a public API.
So you can access it from
Compute Engine or, indeed,
from anywhere.
And so you can build
applications comprising
frontends, using App Engine,
communicating and sharing data
in the middle with Cloud
Datastore, and having backends
on Compute Engine, for
example, all being
synchronized and accessing
that data.
So there are a lot of the
possibilities with the Datastore.
So we think it's a great
addition to the family.
NAVNEET JONEJA: And that pattern
that Martin talked
about is also a great pattern,
one that we recommend, because
it lets you get the best
of both worlds--
App Engine for your scalable
frontends and Compute Engine
for the heavy lifting.
Now it turns out that not all
workloads are created equal.
Some, like databases, benefit
from lots of memory.
Others, like rendering or
processing geographical data,
require lots of processing
power.
When we launched Compute Engine,
we launched with what
we call our standard family of
instances, which had a good
mix of both processing
power and memory.
But we quickly specialized to
offer instances that actually
are more suited to these
specialized workloads that
require more of memory
or compute.
And so we launched instance
families called a high CPU and
high memory instances.
So you have a good diversity of
instances to suit a broad
array of workloads.
And the standard instances are
available in one, two, four
and eight core variance.
And high CPU and high memory
instances are available in
two, four and eight
core variance.
But that's not all.
Today we are also announcing two
new instance types, small
and micro instances, that are
designed for workloads that
don't need as much
processing power.
So for example, if you want to
run a development or test
workload in the Cloud or you
just want to experiment, you
can do so with these instances
for less than $0.02 an hour.
MARTIN GANNHOLM: So as you
design your clusters and think
about how you're going to
orchestrate and get a large
number of machines understanding
what their roles
are, we produced a metadata
server, which is a simple HTTP
server that's exposed into the
guest environment, so you can
just use a simple HTTP
get request to get
metadata that is past.
And we had two forms
of metadata.
One was project level, which
all of your instances would
see the project level
metadata.
And then we also have instance
level metadata where each
individual machine can
have custom metadata
for just that instance.
One of the things that we've
now added is the ability to
mutate this metadata and add
more metadata on the fly.
So you can use this to pass in
changes to your configurations
while your system is running.
You can also use it--
the instance itself can also
make changes to that metadata
to pass information out to some
process on the outside
that wants to understand what's
going on with the instances.
NAVNEET JONEJA: And it turns out
that a lot of people tried
to solve these problems in their
own self built clusters
by using things like agents
to configure and to update
instances when things change.
And with Compute Engine, because
you have access to a
metadata server that's very easy
to program to, you don't
need to do that.
It's built into the service.
Another thing people think about
a lot when they think
about how they deploy sort of
highly robust and scalable
architectures, is how to
make their applications
restartable, repeatable
and resumable.
And so, from the get go, we
provided highly reliable,
persistent disk solution to
let people store their
critical data so they could
do these things.
And our customers really liked
it, and they wanted more.
By more I mean more storage.
And so today we're happy to
announce that you can now
attach up to 10 terabytes of
persistent disk to any Compute
Engine virtual machine, which
really lets you unlock the
power of crunching large amounts
of data and storing
that data reliably.
But it's not just about your
actual application data.
It's also about your virtual
machines, too.
And so we've made it possible
for you to use a persistent
disk as the root file system
for your virtual machine.
What that means is that if you
deploy a virtual machine as a
component in your architecture,
and that
component happens to fail--
because they do, that's
Murphy's law--
you can always bring that
component back up in
practically the same state
where it left off.
Because all the configuration
tweaks you made to that
virtual machine in the root file
system, all the changes
you made to it, were preserved,
and you just spun
up a new instance using the
same persistent disk.
And it's effectively
the same instance.
Take that one step further, and
think about what you can
do when you can actually
attach and detach these
persistent disks on the fly
to your virtual machines.
Because now you can think
about architectures like
having a hot standby where you
can quickly swap a persistent
disk to the hot standby and have
very low downtime if a
component fails.
Or think about what that means
in terms of how you scale.
So it's quite easy to
scale horizontally.
But if you want to scale
vertically, you
could even do that.
So let's say you're running
a database on a standard
instance, and you decide that
you could probably use some
more RAM, because your queries
are not performing as well as
they could.
So you spin up a high memory
instance, and you detach the
persistent disk from your
standard instance.
You attach it to the high memory
instance, and you've
just scaled vertically.
So persistent disk makes
building these architectures
really easy.
And with these changes, we
hope that it'll make your
applications ever more robust
and easier to build.
MARTIN GANNHOLM: Right.
So the Cloud is all
about flexibility.
And so you can spin up a single
instance, or 1,000
instances, at the drop of a hat
as your workload demands.
Now with sub-hour billing, which
we announced today, you
pay for per minute increments.
And this gives you flexibility
also in the time dimension.
No longer do you need to think
about utilizing the full hour
that you will pay for, and you
can instead focus on exactly
what your workloads require.
And so we anticipate that
this will enable new
types of use cases.
When you can spin up your
virtual machines really,
really fast and when you turn
them off, you only pay for the
time that you actually used.
NAVNEET JONEJA: And we combine
that with the fact that
virtual machines spin up really
fast in Compute Engine.
That can actually enable new
kinds of architectures, as
Martin said.
And we've seen at Google-- and
in fact, it's how we build our
applications--
but we haven't really seen
much of in the Cloud.
And we hope that this enables
you to build using on demand
kind of architectures, which
you couldn't earlier.
Now a lot of our customers told
us that they don't look
at the Cloud as a silo.
They want to build applications
that span their
local infrastructure, their
own physical data
centers, and the Cloud.
Or in some cases, they
want to build
applications that span Clouds.
And so we've announced
a new feature
called Advanced Routing.
It's a very deep networking
feature that lets you do lots
of things, including this.
You can actually spin up
gateways and VPNs.
So you can connect your data
centers to the Cloud and share
IP spaces so that you can do
things like augment your on
premise capacity with capacity
in the Cloud, build
multi-Cloud deployments, share
data between applications that
might live in different
locations, and more.
You can also do things like, as
Martin mentioned earlier,
if you remove the public IP from
an instance, you can cut
it off from the internet,
but make it
accessible from inside.
And now using advanced routing
and the fine-grain packet
level routing control you get,
you can do things like
deploying a proxy server or a
gateway to mediate access to
those instances.
So it makes some very, very cool
and powerful and highly
secure architectures possible
when you take full advantage
of this capability.
MARTIN GANNHOLM: All right.
What I want to do now is to give
you a little demo of some
of the features that
we've talked about.
I'm just going to switch
to this one.
Uh oh.
Yeah, I know, but it's--
no.
It's not refreshing.
I broke it, Joe.
NAVNEET JONEJA: Well, you know,
it's a live demo and
stuff breaks, right.
MARTIN GANNHOLM: Total blank.
Oh, I moved to that one.
Open up another tab.
NAVNEET JONEJA: All right.
We'll try and get this fixed.
In the meantime, we'll just move
on to the next segment,
and we'll come back and
get the demo going.
I'd like to invite Sebastian
Stadil, the founder and CEO of
Scalr, to talk to you about what
he thinks is cool about
Compute Engine.
SEBASTIAN STADIL: All right.
Thank you very much, Naveet,
for inviting me.
So it's very exciting
to be here.
I'm super pumped about getting
a Chromebook and all of that.
So I hope you guys are
as excited as I am.
So I'm here to talk about a
couple use cases that we've
seen from our experience at
Scalr with working with
hundreds of customers across
many different Clouds for the
past five years now.
And there's a lot of features
that Compute Engine has that
basically allow us to solve real
customer problems with
greater ease.
So here's a few of the customers
that we've worked
with in the past five years.
Companies big and small.
One of them that I'd like
to point out is Samsung.
They run something like 22% of
the world's Android phones.
They build applications to
manage all of that, and
infrastructure for
it is just huge.
And I'm super excited, because
right now, as I speak, there's
the Eurovision contest.
How many of you here are from
Europe or have heard about
this contest?
Awesome.
So it's like the world's
second largest annual
televised event, between
100 and 120
million televised viewers.
And the voting for it
is extremely spiky.
Now the viewership on any given
day for this is 4x what
you could find at the Olympics
on any given date.
The scale of this event is so
huge, I could even say it
exceeds the Michael Arrington's
ego but maybe
that's a bit--
[LAUGHTER]
SEBASTIAN STADIL: So Ralf
Rottmann, the infrastructure
director that was retained by
Eurovision to run the backend
for this has the following
to say of Compute Engine.
"Google Compute Engine rocks."
Basically, what he loves about
it is it's not just fast,
it's Google fast.
There's a few recent benchmarks
that we ran to
evaluate the speed of
different services.
And one of the figures I'd
like to show is that for
sequential I/O on persistent
disks.
You can see here in blue is
Google, higher is better.
And it's compared to a
well-known competitor.
[LAUGHTER]
SEBASTIAN STADIL: And you can
see here that for a sequential
writes, you get about three
times the amount of
throughputs.
For reads, you get about
twice the amount.
This type of performance is
something that's really
valuable when you're using
[INAUDIBLE] or anything that
writes sequentially.
But Compute Engine isn't
just about the speed,
although we love it.
It's also about the features.
And there's this use case that
we see recurring in the
enterprise which--
think about it this way.
You're building an application
on the Cloud, and that
application needs to access some
resources that you have
in your corporate network.
Now normally you'd have to build
a whole series of things
to get that and secure that,
and go through all sorts of
different vendors.
Compute Engine's routing
capabilities allow you to do
that really, really easily.
They allow you to build that
highly secure tunnel between
Compute Engine and your
corporate network for your
application.
Another use case that we see
very often is the opposite.
When you have applications that
are in your corporate
network, but don't have enough
capacity for them to run,
because they've increased
in size.
And what you have here is you
usually have something called
Cloud bursting, where you're
extending your corporate
network with Cloud resources.
Again, routing makes this
really, really easy.
A second use case that we run
into quite frequently is the
processing of large
amounts of data.
The folks at CERN, specifically,
from the
Lawrence Berkeley Labs just
across the Bay, they're
working on the ATLAS experiments
which is
responsible for managing all the
giant Condor clusters that
are crunching huge
amounts of data.
And that eventually led
to the discovery of
the Higgs boson particle.
So they crunch huge
amounts of data.
And when you're able to mount a
persistent disk to multiple
instances, and when you couple
that with the new limits of 10
terabytes per persistent disk,
it makes it really, really
easy to crunch huge amounts of
data across large amounts of
nodes, without having to manage
a very large number of
volumes and having to version
what's what and
where and all that.
So the use case of crunching
large amounts of data is very
much facilitated.
Now there's another use case
that I like to talk about, so
this is the third one.
And I'm sure if anybody here
has used one of the leading
competitors, a couple years
ago, there were two major
outages that pretty much took
a lot of people offline.
And we had some customers that
were telling us well, this is
unacceptable, there's
a lot of components
that are not reliable.
So we need to architect
around that.
And architecting around
those things
is very, very difficult.
For example, if you can't rely
on a region being up, if you
can't rely on remote disks being
accessible, then you
have to architect around that.
And that's really, really,
really tough.
It's very painful.
I'd say it's like probably even
more painful than sitting
through a "Twilight" movie,
but I don't know.
Yeah.
So the fact that in Compute
Engine you're able to have
every resource that's either a
global resource or a regional
resource, that allows you to
plan what will go down in the
event of a regional outage
and what won't.
So you can plan your
architecture and build your
infrastructure in a much--
so it makes it much
easier to build
highly available systems.
And finally, the last thing
that, of course, as a startup
that I very much appreciate, is
the by the minute pricing.
We have this customer
that has very, very
erratic scaling patterns.
They're very hard to predict,
but when they happen, they're
just explosive.
So they go from x to 20x in
the matter of minutes.
Now what's awesome about by the
minute pricing is that it
dramatically reduces the
risk of scaling up.
If you only need to pay for that
10 minute block instead
of the whole hour, then you
can start scaling at the
slightest hint of having
that peak.
So we're looking at about six
times lower cost of a false
positive here.
So that's huge.
And eventually, that's all
that money that you start
saving, and you might be able
to do cool things like buy a
WinZip license or,
I don't know.
[LAUGHTER]
SEBASTIAN STADIL: But
that money ends up.
So that's the four use cases
that we see Compute Engine
being really powerful.
And we're super excited about
what you guys are building.
So I'd like to hand
it back to Martin.
MARTIN GANNHOLM: Thanks
very much
NAVNEET JONEJA: All right.
SEBASTIAN STADIL: Thank you.
NAVNEET JONEJA: Thanks,
Sebastian.
[APPLAUSE]
MARTIN GANNHOLM: All right.
Joe fixed it.
Thank you, Joe.
So I was going to show you a
little demo here highlighting
some of the features
that we have.
I'm just going to start by
kicking off a bunch of VMs,
and I'll talk through what's
happening here.
So what you're looking at here
is a web page that is backed
by an App Engine application
that is controlling the
Compute Engine through
the API.
And so what it did is on the
left hand side, it started up
a cluster of one instance and,
on the right hand side, is a
cluster of eight.
As you can see, as it's coming
up here, the green means that
these VMs are actually running
and they're now just getting
ready to be able to serve tiles
in a Mandelbrot set.
So we basically are going to
show you some cool Mandelbrot
fractals here.
And so on the right hand side,
this eight machine
cluster has shown up.
And here on the left hand
side, we have the single
instance has launched.
So you see that's how fast
we can launch a bunch of
instances on Compute Engine.
And these are now two core
high CPU instances.
So let me show the maps.
So using the Maps API here to
basically just jump around and
get some tiling behavior.
And you can see that the right
hand side is a lot faster.
Now I'm just a single user using
this, and so it doesn't
demonstrate the full scalability
of this.
And so if it was multiple users
hitting this at the same
time, you'd see the scalability
much better.
But it's pretty cool anyway.
Ooh, this is one of
my favorites.
This is pretty complex.
This one takes much
longer to render.
All right.
So one of the interesting
things here is that the
virtual machines are vanilla
images that we launch.
And all of the configuration
data, all of the instructions
for what they should be doing,
are passed into the virtual
machines through our
metadata server.
And so, in fact, since this is
Go program, we are actually
passing the source code of the
Go program in one of metadata
values, and that gets read by
the virtual machine as part of
the start-up script.
And it compiles it on the fly
and then renders these things.
So that's an interesting
use of our metadata
server right there.
So let me show you what happens
if I go over to the
Cloud Console.
So the Cloud Console
is a new home--
and, actually, let
me go back here--
a new home for all of our Cloud
services, where you can
manage and see all the resources
that you're using.
You can see billing information
and all
this kind of stuff.
And so I'll just jump back into
the Compute Engine piece.
And here, we see a list
of our instances.
And so right now, I have eight
instances here, and then I
have a single one over here.
Now what I can do is I can
add virtual machines.
And we've programmed this so I
can just click this button,
and it'll start spinning up
virtual machines here.
And one of the things that I'm
previewing for you here today
is it says, using load balance
up at the top.
And so this is an upcoming
feature of Compute Engine that
we are showing you where it's a
load balancer as a service.
And so adding virtual machines
is really easy.
You just spin them up and add
them to your pool of servers
for that work, and smoothly
you can remove machines.
And so as I click around, those
things will be spun up.
And I shouldn't have been
doing this while
it was coming up.
But as they get health checked--
that's what the
white checkmark means--
they basically get included
into that.
Another fun thing I can do is I
can, of course, just go into
any one of these instances.
We can look at this,
and here, you can
actually see the Go program.
It's really quite long, but we
can't see the whole thing.
It's one of the metadata
pieces.
And I can just simulate
a failure.
So I'm just going to delete
this instance.
So we'll blow that away.
And now, as I'm scrolling around
and doing stuff here,
you'll notice that everything
still keeps working, and our
application detects that
that machine is gone.
So it highlights, updates the
little graphic we have there.
And of course, I can just spin
everything down by hitting the
Stop VMs right here.
And as you see, in this view,
you'll start seeing these
things terminate
and disappear.
One other thing I want to point
out here is that you'll
see a metric being shown on
this graph, which is CPU
utilization.
And so this is another preview
feature of an upcoming Compute
Engine feature, which is a
monitoring API where we will
expose a number of metrics out
of the virtual machine, and we
will add to those metrics
over time as well.
And now all our instances
have shut down.
So I think that's it for
the demo, and we'll
switch back to slides.
[APPLAUSE]
NAVNEET JONEJA: Thanks,
Martin.
And thank you, Joe.
So as I mentioned earlier, this
is an overview session.
We haven't had time to go into
much technical depth about any
of the features, but we wanted
to give you an overall flavor
of Compute Engine.
But we have deep dive sessions
into a number of things that
we've talked about today.
Speed, efficiency and control is
a deep dive session on our
advanced networking stack.
I highly encourage those of you
who are interested in this
stuff to go attend.
It's going to be a
really cool talk.
We have a great talk on
persistent disk later this
evening, actually, where they're
actually not only
going to tell you how to use
persistent disk and talk about
using it in an application, but
even give you a little bit
of the behind the scenes glimpse
at the architecture
and product itself.
We have a session that is
focused on how you can build
robust high availability
applications in the Cloud.
It's called When Bad Things
Happen to Good Clusters.
And then we have a Code Lab on
Friday morning, which will
help you get your hands dirty
with Compute Engine, play
around with some astronomical
data, and just get a feel for
the products.
Should be a really cool,
fun session.
And, of course, we have some
time for questions today, but
we'll also be at the Sandbox
from time to time.
We have Office Hours tomorrow,
if you want to come by and
chat one on one, ask any
question you have of us.
We'll be available to you.
So, one more thing, we're happy
to announce that Compute
Engine is now available
to sign up online.
We'll be flipping the switch
shortly after this talk.
You can go online, sign up for
Compute Engine, play with it,
spin up a virtual machine
for under $0.02 an hour.
Tell us what you think.
Tell us how we can make the
service better for you.
We'd love to have you play
with the service, give us
feedback, and tell us what
you need from it.
[APPLAUSE]
NAVNEET JONEJA: If you're
interested in playing with the
two new preview features
Martin talked
about earlier today--
the load balancing capabilities
as well as the
monitoring APIs--
we actually have them
available to a
small set of customers.
And we'd love to have more
people come play with them,
give us feedback, help evolve
these features, tell us what
matters to you.
So we have an early
access program.
The URL is on the
screen up there.
Come apply, give us feedback,
be the first to tell us what
you like, tell us what
you don't like--
especially what you
don't like--
so we can make it
better for you.
Thank you very much.
MARTIN GANNHOLM: All right.
Thank you.
And I think we can take
questions now.
I would like to invite to
Sebastian back up on stage,
and also a Joe Beda, who is
the tech lead on Compute
Engine, who will field the most
difficult technical questions.
JOE BEDA: So why did
the demo fail?
Does anybody want to know?
I was running it on an unpaid
App Engine instance, and I hit
a quota limit.
And so I entered my credit card
up here frantically while
you guys all watched.
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
JOE BEDA: And in that vein, I'm
going to be hosting the
robustness talk later.
[LAUGHTER]
MARTIN GANNHOLM: All right.
We can start with you.
AUDIENCE: Maybe this is a
question better for the
persistent disk session, but
I'll just ask it anyways.
What's the consistency semantics
associated with
multiple Google engines
writing to the
same persistent disk?
Let's say they are writing
to the same file.
MARTIN GANNHOLM: So you can only
attach a persistent disk,
a read/write, to a single
instance at a time.
We do have the capability of
mounting read only, a single
persistent disk, to many
VMs at the same time.
But that's in read only mode.
So you can share data across
them that way.
JOE BEDA: And you're free to do
something like run an NFS
server on an instance hosting
a persistent disk and then
export that to other virtual
machines, if you need to share
a file system.
SEBASTIAN STADIL: In our
benchmarks we've run, there's
no degradation of performance
when you're reading it from
multiple servers.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MARTIN GANNHOLM: All right.
Over here.
AUDIENCE: What is your plans
with Google's customer support
surrounding this whole thing,
given the history of Google
and customer support?
MARTIN GANNHOLM: So we've
already launched the ability
to get premium support.
We have a gold support
program.
We launched that about
a month and a half or
maybe two months ago.
So you can actually get
developer support, talk to a
real person on the phone, as
well as submit tickets.
So that's already a capability
you can have.
We're also very responsive to
feedback, and we watch Stack
Overflow and stuff as well.
So if you have sort of
non-urgent development
questions, we're quite
responsive.
MARTIN GANNHOLM: All right.
This side.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned the
performance difference between
a compute Cloud and other
Cloud providers.
But what's the performance
difference, if there is any,
between the Compute server
and App Engine?
NAVNEET JONEJA: That's
a great question.
So I think you're comparing
apples and oranges.
Right?
There's no such thing as a
Compute Engine performance.
Right?
You deploy Apache,
you deploy no JS.
You'd deploy something else.
Performance varies, right?
It depends on the entire
stack you build.
With App Engine you get a fully
managed stack where
performance is taken care
of you, scalability is
taken care for you.
So think about the platform
versus the infrastructure.
So you can do a lot of things
with Compute Engine, but if
you write bad code, it
won't do very well.
So you just can't
compare the two.
It's not a fair comparison.
MARTIN GANNHOLM: We
invite you to try.
If you have workloads that could
be suited for either,
then if you want to manage the
infrastructure and you need
that control, then
Compute Engine is
probably your choice.
But if you would be happy with
having all that managed for
you, and you get the performance
and the price
points and everything else--
I mean, all the different
factors are what you want--
then you should make
that trade off.
So we offer multiple products
so you can use whatever is
best in your particular
situation.
All right.
Over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
You mentioned that security was
sort of like a major point
of Google Compute Engine.
I was wondering when you might
be going through any of the
certifications.
For example, FedRAMP?
NAVNEET JONEJA: So the ISO27k
is probably one of the most
common certifications around
information security.
And I didn't mention it today,
but we actually have recently
gotten ISO27k certification.
So that's one of the
areas we've done.
We're also looking at additional
areas where
certification matters to our
customers, and you'll hear
more about that in the days
and months to come.
AUDIENCE: Anything specifically
on FedRAMP?
NAVNEET JONEJA: I am not sure
about that, but if you come
and find me at the Sandbox,
I'll get you an answer.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MARTIN GANNHOLM: All right.
Over here.
AUDIENCE: If I want to connect
from Google Compute Engine
instance to the Cloud Datastore
product, is that
going to have better latency
significantly compared to
connecting to that from
another Cloud?
JOE BEDA: In general, connecting
from Compute Engine
to other Google services,
you're going to get the
fastest connection from
within Compute Engine.
Not everything is hosted
everywhere.
These things have physical
locations, and there's the
speed of light.
But we're continually working
on optimizing the connection
between Compute Engine and other
Google services, whether
they be Cloud services
or other APIs
or services at Google.
MARTIN GANNHOLM: And as you
access other Google services,
your traffic stays on
the Google network.
So you won't be subject to the
variance in the general
internet in those
cases as well.
All right.
Over here.
AUDIENCE: So beyond Debian and
CentOS, anything for Ubuntu or
Microsoft OS's?
NAVNEET JONEJA: So right now,
our focus is on working with
the community to provide
community supported
distributions as part
of our images.
We've worked with both the
Debian and the CentOS
communities to bring those
images to Compute Engine.
We'd be happy to engage with
any of the other free Linux
providers who want to make the
images available as part of
our default images in
Compute Engine.
In terms of Microsoft, we've
heard that from customers.
We'd love to chat with you more
about your use case and
see where that falls in
our priority list.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My question is, is the App
Engine Datastore being renamed
or re-branded as Cloud
Datastore?
If the answer is yes, how do I
get my existing data that is
being accessed by an App Engine
application to be
accessed from a Google Compute
Engine application?
If the answer is no, how do I
copy the data from an App
Engine Datastore to the
Cloud Datastore?
JOE BEDA: I actually
don't know.
Why don't you grab us
afterwards, and we'll find the
right people who can give
you that information.
AUDIENCE: I'll hang it on.
Thank you.
JOE BEDA: Is there a
session on the app?
MARTIN GANNHOLM: I think
I know what it is.
Yes, there's definitely a
session on Datastore.
JOE BEDA: Yeah.
And I think, definitely go to
that session, and they're
going to go into the Cloud
Datastore a lot deeper.
MARTIN GANNHOLM: But you can
also find us and we can--
JOE BEDA: We can find
the right person.
MARTIN GANNHOLM: I think I know
the answer, and I think
it's the answer you want.
But we need to verify.
AUDIENCE: I'll hang it on.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: You talked about
the advanced routing.
Is it very similar to your
favorite competitors
[INAUDIBLE]
private Cloud, or it's
not there yet?
NAVNEET JONEJA: Advanced
routing--
so, in general, I will think
of advanced routing-- so if
you've looked at the
abstractions of the Compute
Engine at all, there's always
been this hint that there's
this virtual router behind
the scenes, this
software defined router.
We never gave any knobs and sort
of ways to configure it.
And so advanced routing actually
makes that virtual
router configurable by you.
So it lets you do all those
things, but it's not a hosted
service per se, that does
higher level things.
It gives you the tools so you
can do the stuff yourself.
So it's very powerful, but it
takes some work on your part.
But you can do a lot with it.
Does that answer
your question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
NAVNEET JONEJA: Thank you.
SEBASTIAN STADIL: I'd
like to add to that.
I assume that you're referring
to some service that starts
with a V. That particular
service is very complex.
Compared to that, routing is
very easy to work with.
That's been our experience.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
NAVNEET JONEJA: So
I apologize.
We are out of time.
We'll just head to the back,
and you can chat with us
outside if you have any
more questions.
MARTIN GANNHOLM: All right.
NAVNEET JONEJA: Thank you.
MARTIN GANNHOLM: Thank
you again for coming.
[APPLAUSE]